constitution liberté et dignité
nationale à des nombreux slogans qu'on
pouvait lire sur les pancartes des
manifestants réunis dimanche devant le
théâtre municipal de tunis plus d'un
millier de personnes s'étaient donné
rendez-vous à l'appel de certains partis
d'opposition comme le parti islamiste
ennahda ou encore le parti el karama
pour dénoncer les mesures
exceptionnelles décrété par le président
saïd renforçant ainsi ses pouvoirs un
important dispositif de sécurité avait
été déployé sur l'avenue bourguiba au
coeur de la capitale pour prévenir tout
risque de débordements entre les pro et
anti el sayed pour les opposants au chef
de l'état autant de pouvoirs entre les
mains d'un seul homme constitue un
risque pour les acquis démocratiques de
la révolution de 2011 certains n'ont pas
hésité à comparer l'actuel président à
l'ancien autocrate zine abedine ben ali
disant craindre un retour à l'état
policier écouter
aujourd'hui en tant que représentant du
peuple nous sommes toujours dans notre
capacité parlementaire selon tous les
décret constitutionnel du président de
la république qui a renversé la
constitution de la deuxième république
aujourd'hui nous sortons dans la rue et
nous nous opposons au coup d'état le
coup d'état qu'est devenu décisif en
tunisie le coût qui est menée pour
violer la constitution tunisienne et
tous ces chapitres
aujourd'hui nous sommes ici pour
défendre la liberté les institutions
pour lesquelles nos martyrs sont morts
et pour lesquels nous avons vécu
soixante ans de sacrifices pour avoir un
pays démocratique
aujourd'hui nous exigeons le retour du
système républicain qui a été abolie et
le retour de la constitution à laquelle
on fait référence pour passer à un
régime populiste anti constitutionnelle
nous voulons continuer avec la
constitution de 2014
elles viennent de militants de
l'opposition d'acteurs de la société
civile ou de juristes de plus en plus de
voix s'élèvent contre les décisions du
président sayed notamment au sujet d'un
texte publié au journal officiel qui se
substitue à plusieurs articles de la
constitution et contient de nouvelles
mesures d'exception le 25 juillet
dernier kaïs saïd avait surpris tout le
monde en limogeant le premier ministre
est en jeu l'an les activités du
parlement deux mois plus tard alors que
le palais de carthage devrait annoncer
prochainement la nomination d'un nouveau
chef du gouvernement des tunisiens
demeure dans l'expectative car la
perspective d'une sortie de crise
politique reste incertaine